[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, my name is Ed Rex,
and I founded Jukedeck.
At Jukedeck, we've
built software
that writes original music
at the touch of a button.
What that means is,
you can use this
to create unique
music for your videos.
And if you want to hear
what it sounds like,
it's actually providing the
music for this video right now.
We've raised a couple
of rounds of investment.
And I'd just like to share with
you a few tips we've picked up
along the way on
how to raise money.
So I think there
are four questions
you need to ask yourself
when you're raising money--
when to raise; who to raise
from; how to approach them;
and what they want to see.
So the first question to
ask is when to raise money.
And I think it's different
if you're at seed stage
or if you're a bit
later in your journey.
At seed stage, you
don't even want
to think about raising
money until you've
proved your idea has legs.
And that's for two reasons.
Firstly, investors
just aren't going
to listen to you until you do.
And secondly, and more
importantly, you're
wasting your own time
if you're raising money
for something you
don't know works.
So for us, what
that meant was we
spent quite a lot of
time building software
before we actually went to
investors in the first place.
By the time we went to them,
we had a prototype that worked.
And we had something
really good to show them.
And that really
helped us raise money.
So it's a bit
different if you're
raising money at a later stage.
What we've found
is that you really
need to start raising
money before you need it.
Because if you wait
until you need it,
you're not going
to get a good deal.
You're going to be desperate
when you go and speak
to investors, and that's not
a good position to be in.
The other thing we found is that
you really have to start early.
It takes a surprising amount
of time to raise investment.
It took us six to nine months.
And you really need
to plan in advance
and start work on it in
advance, because otherwise,
if you start three months
before you run out of money,
you're going to be
in lot of trouble.
The next question to ask is who
you should raise money from.
You might be tempted to
spread a lot of paint,
to get in touch with as
many people as you can.
But actually, what
you really need
is investors who are interested
in what you're doing.
If you're a music
company like us
and you go to someone who
only invests in social media,
you're wasting everyone's time.
Now, we actually got very lucky
in that one of the first people
we talked to, a
lovely guy named Mike,
had worked on
generative music-- which
is what we're doing-- before.
So he knew how hard
what we're doing is.
And he gave our stuff
a listen and said,
you're doing it
quite well, actually.
So maybe we'll invest.
But you don't want them
to be too interested.
If you go to an investor who's
invested in something a bit
like you before,
they either are going
to be put off because
that thing didn't work,
or that thing will
still be going,
and you'll essentially
be its competition.
If you go to that
kind of person,
again, you're wasting time.
So you need to find the balance.
You need to find someone who's
interested in what you're
doing, but not so
interested that they've
been through it before.
So once you figure
out who to approach,
you need to think about
how to approach them.
Now, I got this very wrong
the first time around.
I sent out a lot of
emails to a lot of people.
And not many of
them got back to me,
presumably because--
I hope-- they
have much more
important things to do
than replying to
every email they get.
Instead, what I found
is the best way to get
these people's attention is
to cultivate relationships
with them.
You know, if these
people are going
to be investing money
in your startup,
they really want to know you.
They are going to want to
invest in people they know,
in people they've talked to
a lot, in people they like.
And what it comes
down to ultimately
is, it's all about
personal relationships.
You need to go to as
many events as you can.
You need to talk to as
many people as you can.
You need to put yourself
out there, so that you meet,
eventually, the right people.
The first people you
meet won't necessarily
be the people who invest.
But ultimately, if you
get out there enough,
you'll find the people
who are right for you.
Now, forging personal
relationships
can be tricky,
especially for the kind
of people who run startups.
I think one thing that really
helps is personal intros.
If you get someone you know
to intro you to an investor,
they're always going to listen
much more than if you just
go up to them and chat
to them at a conference.
Any sort of intro you
can get from anyone
who knows them is a really,
really valuable thing.
It's sort of annoying
that you have to do this.
You want your idea to be
judged purely on its merits.
But ultimately, that's not
the way the world works.
And you have to get
people to vouch for you.
And the fourth
and final question
to ask yourself is what
an investor is going
to want to see when you
do go and chat to them.
There are a couple of
things to think about here.
The first is quite an obvious
point, which is traction.
Investors are
really going to want
to see that people
using your product.
Investors are going
to want to see
that your product is being used.
Otherwise, they're not
going to invest in it.
But what's interesting,
I've found,
is that traction
doesn't mean you
have to have thousands, millions
of people using your product.
A great definition
of traction that I
got from a good friend
who worked at Index
is that traction is
irrational usage.
Even if you only have five
people using your product,
if you can show that they're
coming back to it all the time
and they absolutely
love it, you've
got something really
exciting on your hands.
An investor doesn't need
to see huge, huge metrics.
They just need to see
retention, because then you
can go back to them
and say, you see this.
We've made it work.
Now we need to scale it.
That's why we need your money.
The other thing we
found really useful
is taking a prototype
to investors.
If you turn up and all
you have is an idea,
it can be really
hard to convince them
of the benefits of
what you're doing.
But if you have
something to show them,
if you can put
something in their hands
that they can play with,
that's a really powerful way
of demonstrating exactly
what you're doing.
And you're much more likely to
really grab their attention.
So I remember, in our
first investment meeting,
we took along our prototype.
And the real moment
of excitement
came when we had it
up on the big screen.
We pressed go, and it wrote
an original piece of music
right there.
That was the moment
in which are investors
said, OK, maybe
there's something here.
So there you go-- four questions
I think you should ask yourself
when you're trying
to raise investment.
When should you raise?
Who should you raise it from?
How should you approach them?
And what do they want to see?